today your boy Shamar Franklin Moore is
about to find out if he's gonna be a
daddy
to a little girl or to a little boy I'm
about to be a father well Shemar Moore
is officially a daddy to a baby girl
baby girl on Tuesday a rep for the
Criminal Mind star confirmed to E.T that
Shamar and his girlfriend Desiree design
welcomed their first child together
Shamar also shared the news on Instagram
writing your boy is officially a dad
dreams come true the rest of my life is
here I'm proud of what I've accomplished
I'm blessed the actor first revealed the
happy news that they were expecting
earlier this month on Instagram sharing
a sweet clip from their epic gender
reveal party
no seriously guys they recruited a
helicopter for the big moment
what is about to happen right
I need to know
all right
foreign
[Applause]
but before the couple learned what they
were having Shamar gave a sweet shout
out to his mom who died three years ago
mama I did it Mama's in heaven I miss
her so much I wish she was here she's
smiling she's so proud we wanted to make
this happen while you were here but
you're still a part of all of this the
actor paid tribute to his late Mom in
the caption writing Mama smiling from
Heaven miracles happen here comes the
best part of my life and all that Echoes
what chamar told E.T last year do you
wanna do you want to feel that just love
someday you want to be a daddy still
you've said that you've told me before
that you do I do you know I mean
especially with the loss of my mother
you know and and you know she left too
soon she was only 76 years old and and
What Hurts the Most about losing her is
we had a plan everything you know you
know all through my life it was me and
her you know it was like you know we
started the day you know checking on
Mama and finish the day and then and I
would go out in the day just trying to
make her proud I as for Shamar and
Desiree the two have kept their love
pretty private but we expect to learn
more on the Jennifer Hudson show on
January 26th when shemar's big interview
about baby heirs I was worried for a
while that maybe that ship had sailed
kind of thing and and you know God had
my back and things lined up and uh it's
going to be the best part of my life is
pretty Grand but I know whenever God
does Call My Name once I get this
experience I'll be able to go to heaven
whole
foreign